thank you
so Toby for the magazine this week you
write that Labor's policy to add taxes
onto private schools would lose the
treasury money harm social mobility and
won't make the education system fairer
can we start with the first part of that
I mean how would a treasury actually
lose money by levying this tax
yeah well um labor estimates that um
this will raise about 1.7 billion and
it's announced I think various things it
intended to spend this bounty on but
according to an analysis by a financial
consultancy company called Baines Cutler
which provides consultancy services to
Independent Schools it would actually
lose the treasury money and the way they
work this out is first of all I mean I
think that where um uh Kia Stormer has
got the 1.6 billion from the 1.7 billion
is first of all 1.6 would just be
multiplying what parents are currently
paying by way of private school fees by
20 and then you add the additional
amount that private schools will be
paying when they're forced to pay full
business rates
um but the problem is that when you make
schools when you make school fees liable
for vat schools can then claim back some
of their some of the vat they're playing
on supplies which means they can
probably lower their fees a little bit
and according to base Cutler actually
the Bounty will be more like 15 of what
parents are paying now rather than 20
and in addition and this is the really
critical Factor because that will
nevertheless make private school fees
unaffordable for vast suede's appearance
people imagine that if you're sending
your child to a private school you're
very wealthy or a member of the super
rich not true often middle class
families making sacrifices
um one one partner giving up all their
salary to pay children school fees so if
they do go up I mean it's price
sensitive if they do go up Ben's Cutler
estimates that about a quarter of
private school students will move into
the state sector so that's reducing the
take by another 25 but critically if
they have to move into the state sector
the state then has to pay to educate
them in the state sector and not only
does that mean paying for more teachers
it also means building new classrooms
and Bank Cutler estimate that the total
cost to the treasury will be about 416
million a year over the five-year period
of the next Labor government well Fiona
do you agree with those calculations
well I mean the first point to make is
that there's the government's own
figures say that the school role is
going to drop by a million pounds over
the a million pupils over the next
decade so that there is a lot of spare
capacity in the system and give you one
example I mean there are 80 000 School
places in London at the moment that
aren't filled the 90 000 pupils in the
private sector so they could easily be
accommodated without any extra cost and
I mean this 25 it seems is a sort of
rough estimate nobody knows how many
parents would come back into the state
sector but for me it it isn't even a
matter really of the money it's a matter
of principle there are eight million
children in state schools including our
own Toby who are funded at about five
thousand pounds per pupil per year there
are half a million children in private
schools funded approximately fifteen
thousand pounds a year and that's
fundamentally unfair you cannot have a
system where a small minority of
children are funded to such an extent
that's therefore that's then subsidized
by the taxpayer in this way so I think
it's a political argument we don't
believe in subsidizing the education of
the most well-off in society we we
believe in redistributing the money
however much it is to the least well-off
who bloody well needed at the moment I I
think you've got it um back to front
Fiona it's not that the taxpayer are
subsidizing uh taxpayers are subsidizing
private school parents uh it's the other
way around
um private school parents are paying
twice over for Education once for their
own children's education and the second
time for other people's children's
education
um uh and you know it it seems to be
looking a gift horse in the mouth to say
to these parents who are paying twice
over for education and paying for other
people's children as well as their own
sorry you're going to have to pay more
for your own children's education I mean
aren't they paying enough given that
they're paying twice you don't you don't
say to people please leave the National
Health Service and go privately to save
the state money we want public services
that are used by everybody across the
community that's what gives them their
status and their validity in society if
they've become just a rump service for
poorer people they're done for so I
think we want we want public services to
be used by everyone and I would welcome
back all those parents into the state
sector and I'm sure they'll find it's
much better than they think it is and
they would enrich all their local state
schools as you've always known I make
that case well we can go back and forth
about whether it would actually
um cost the taxpayer money or the
taxpayer would gain but let's let's just
take it for granted that it's cost can I
ask you a question do you accept that it
is fair that a small group of pupils in
this country are funded to such a a a
lavish extent compared to the majority
of children in the state do you think
that's fair one of the the points I make
in my article Fiona is that about five
years ago I was the co-author along with
several people of a paper that was
published in a peer-reviewed scientific
journal in which we looked at the GCSE
performance of a group of private school
pupils and a group of pupils at State
schools controlling for all the
characteristics they arrived at the
schools with so prior attainment
parental socioeconomic status the
genetic markers associated with with
educational achievement and we found
that if you control for all those
factors the GCSE results of children in
private schools are really no different
to the GCSE results of children in state
schools Toby does the inequality come a
bit later down the line then when it
comes to universities because private
school children are disproportionately
more likely to get into Oxbridge for
example yeah but you can't just look at
that Cindy you have to look at whether
if you control for all the all the
characteristics they bring with them
when they arrive at the school they're
still doing better and children with
those same characteristics at State
schools are just as likely to get into
universities you can't just look at the
percentage of people in private schools
or getting to universities you have to
look at whether they're actually getting
a leg up in virtue of going to private
schools and the evidence suggests
they're not
well in terms of exam grades no but of
course people there's a lot more to
private education than just the exam
results and anyway you're talking about
one sliver of State School educated
pupils the ones I'm talking about are
the poorest ones who'd never be in the
private sector in the first place you're
paying for the the sports facilities
you're paying for the contacts you're
paying for the the tutors and the sixth
form will help you get into Oxford and
Cambridge you're paying for the drama
you're paying for the enrichment you're
paying for the school trips and things
you know that is just not affordable in
the state sector at the moment that's
fundamentally unfair you could say it's
unfair that some people live in bigger
houses
um but I think let's look you say Fiona
that you're concerned about the least
well-off children and how they're doing
in state schools I say in my article and
I think this is an argument you'd
understand that if you force lots of
aspirational middle class parents to
educate their children in the state
sector because you make private school
fees unaffordable they're going to find
places in the highest performing State
schools and that's going to push out but
we know this you know
whereas children are not in the highest
performing States when this when a
school is doing well a state school a
good comprehensive middle class parents
will move Heaven and Earth they'll game
the system to get their children in
whether it means going to church and
pretending to be past Christians buying
property in the catchment area of the
school whatever it takes they'll do it
to get their child into the high
performing school and the children that
will suffer as a result of all that
migration from the private to the state
sector are the disadvantaged children
that currently candidate they're not in
those schools Toby they're not in those
schools you know that perfectly well
they're not in those schools they're not
in the grammar Schools they're not in
the selective Church Schools they're in
the schools that you know don't fiddle
their admissions in that way and
incidentally you know perfectly well
that I've always been in favor of
admissions reform so I would make that a
big labor policy alongside this one so
that you did make access to the best
best schools more accessible to the
poorest children I'm just interested in
how we get invest more money in the
education of the poorest children in
society at a time when the Gap is
widening not narrowing between the
richest and the poorest and I think it's
frankly obscene that the funding
differentials between the state and the
private schools are so extreme that
anything we can do to narrow that is a
good thing and I think that's what this
proposal is attempting to do but Fiona
if the sums don't add up in a way that
Toby has set out what is the point I
don't accept they don't add up because I
think there's plenty of capacity in the
state system and I've told you the
government's own figures say they're
going to be a million extra places in
the next decade there's plenty of
capacity in the state system as it is
funded at the moment to absorb extra
children in fact the state system would
would very much love to have those extra
children because otherwise State schools
are going to have to close Fiona the the
schools which have spare capacity are
the least successful schools the schools
that parents don't want to send their
children to and the middle class
children the refugees from the private
sector you know as well as me are not
going to end up in those schools it's
the children they push out of the better
schools that are going to be shunted
into those low performing schools I can
give you many examples of State schools
that have been turned around by the
arrival of a group of motivated middle
class parents and I'm sure you know many
of them yourself so I don't ex all I'm
not what I'm saying is that the money is
there to fund a million pupils at the
moment who won't be there in 10 years
time so that it's not going to cost the
state any more money if 20 even if 150
000 children come in from the state
sector and also as you perfectly well
know these State these private school
places are distributed to very unequally
across the country they tend to be in
certain cities and they're huge sways
that countries don't have many children
in private education so in places like
London where there are a lot of extra
School places at the moment it would be
perfectly easy to to accommodate them
even in what a perfectly good schools at
the moment can we can we talk a little
bit more about something that both of
you have mentioned which is how middle
class Parents game the system you know
if you know you mentioned admissions
reform how would that look like when it
comes to the state sector because you
know I went to a grammar school and I
saw lots of middle class parents who
probably could have afforded private
education but because my grammar school
was so good they put them into the
catchment area and to put them through
the 11 plus for that school and and as
you say pushed out people who otherwise
uh would have got there but the 11 plus
is the biggest middle class you know
Swindle to get into school because you
can pay for coaching for your children
from the age of seven or eight to pass
the test and that's why grammar schools
have very very few children eligible for
free School meals or the pupil premiums
so that needs to go for a start I think
the way the church schools and many
Church schools admit their pupils need
to be looked at and I think that the
proximity uh criteria need to be look at
because that means people can buy houses
in those areas I would certainly reform
all that as well you know I mean that
would be a bigger priority for me in a
way but we're not talking about at the
moment we're talking about charity
successive labor governments have failed
to enact those admissions I'm not
entertaining I'm not a member of the
labor party I'm not arguing it's not
going to happen it's politically too
difficult it's too unpopular grammar
schools are located in marginal
constituencies
this policy as a kind of Elixir which
will cure unfairness in the system but
you know that without admissions reform
it'll just have a negative impact on
social Mobility not a positive one can I
make another point in connection with
social Mobility Cindy which is that at
the moment in order to retain their
charitable status Independent Schools do
an enormous amount of work to try and
help uh less Advantage children get us
get a step up so about 85 percent of
Independent Schools have partnership
arrangements with local state schools
the school that I helped set up in West
London the West London free school has
an arrangement with Latimer a next door
private school they let us use some of
their facilities yeah Crumbs from the
rich man's table exactly pupils there
are 40 000 pupils in the independent
school sector that benefit from
scholarships and bursaries Kia starmer
himself was the beneficiary of a bursary
when he went to reigate grammar school
all those children currently getting a
leg up being given a helping hand by the
independent sector it won't stop
altogether but they won't have the same
incentive to engage in that partnership
work to create those personalities if
there's no tax benefits
one percent of children in the private
sector on full bursaries right unless
you're on a full bursary it's going to
be quite expensive for you some of those
bursaries are offered to families who
earn a hundred thousand pounds a year
plus
and they're mostly linked to
academically selective tests so they're
not you're not going to be you know
perfectly well you're not going to be
taking the most disadvantaged primary
school peoples you're going to be taking
in the pupils who have come coached or
who've kept up through Primary School to
pass the selective test and the question
I always ask private school heads is how
many children in your schools do you
have who are eligible for the pupil
premium or how many are there across the
independent sector answer comes they're
none because they don't count them
because there aren't any and frankly if
these schools were doing so much to
address disadvantage they should be able
to answer that question
don't you think
uh I'm sure well you know I think the
figures I've been the figures I've got
are that 40 000 children benefit from
bursaries and scholarships but they're
families you earn up they can earn up
with upwards of 40 56
56 pounds
taking School if it's affordable for
those who currently can't afford it
because they're not particularly well
off it's a myth to think that only the
super rich can afford private education
but why is making school fees affordable
for
people why would that be our priority
when we're talking about leveling up
what be worried about what's happening
to those millions of children who have
who are not funded well enough to get
the chances in life that they need and
if this policy can even throw half a
million pounds back into the state
sector frankly it's a good thing in my
view can I suggest that can I suggest a
middle ground here instead of scrapping
charitable status all together
um can we say that the threshold you
have to meet to to Get Charitable status
the stuff you have to contribute back to
the community back to your local state
schools has to be much much higher you
know Toby I hear you what you're saying
about these statistics but I think we
all know private schools that do the
bare minimum in order to kind of meet
some kind of charitable responsibility
you know private schools who let the
local state school use their swimming
pool for two hours a week or something
like that you know that's just not
enough you know even if you count the
bursaries why don't we say raise the
threshold if you can meet the threshold
where you're really helping local state
schools then you can keep that
charitable status and if you can't then
you don't do you think that would work
to be I I've got no objection to making
the
um burdens on governors of Independent
Schools even higher to retain their tax
benefits but I just can't see
um how you can believe that charging VAT
on school fees and charging full
business rates on school buildings is
actually going to bring in money given
that the number of children that will
have to move out of that sector and be
educated in the state sector as a
consequence even if there are empty
places you're still going to have to
employ more teachers
otherwise would if those children would
continue to be educated in the private
sector no those teachers are coming
currently being employed by the state
sector because as pupils go you won't
need as many of them so the budget is
there now but the point is I think that
is a very good idea and so what about
this for an idea why did we say to the
Independent Schools if you want to keep
your charitable status you take in the
pupils who are hardest to teach most
likely to be excluded can't pass your
academic selective tests you know live
at the council flat that most of those
parents are trying to get children away
from why do you take them in and let's
see what they say I can tell you what
they'll say they won't want it because
that's not what their parents are paying
for it's an interesting point Fiona
which is that many pupil referral units
many special schools schools for
children with special educational needs
are Independent Schools they charge fees
usually those fees are paid by the local
Authority not in every case when labor
says it's going to charge VAT on
independent school fees and charge full
business rates for school buildings in
the private sector does it mean those
schools as well and if not has it going
to differentiate between some private
schools but not all private schools I
think we're gonna have to leave it there
because we are running out of time but
Fiona and Toby thanks very much and I
hope that kills them or someone in labor
is is watching because maybe we've come
out with a middle ground
thank you